let's talk a little bit about Noam
Chomsky Noam Chomsky's a linguist and a
philosopher he's now 91 years old and
he's had some pretty damn good takes
lately that have unfortunately really
rattled and shaken up a slice of the
American left-wing that's very very anti
Joe Biden so as an example a few months
ago maybe it was a month ago Noam
Chomsky said of course I'm going to vote
for Joe Biden and everybody should vote
for Joe Biden and that was the take and
it was not particularly controversial
but there were a lot of people who were
very upset with Noam Chomsky saying that
he has sold out in some way but I was
glad to hear him say it because there's
definitely crossover between Bernie fans
and Chomsky fans and not all of them
agree that voting Trump out to replace
him with Biden is good now I believe
that that is good that is the right
decision to make so does Noam Chomsky
Noam Chomsky was recently interviewed by
Michael Brooks who has some clips on our
channel if you go back in the archives a
little bit and Chomsky said Trump is
undeniably the worst criminal in history
and what I like about this is that
Chomsky has shown a commitment not to
allow the forest to be missed for the
trees when people start getting into
well you know back in the 90s Biden
didn't take Social Security cuts off the
table so that means he's running today
on cutting Social Security you know it's
like hold up hold on a second hold on a
second
Biden is not running on cutting Social
Security today in the 90s Biden said I
wouldn't preemptively take it off the
table in a negotiation while I disagree
with what Biden said in the 90s that was
almost 30 years ago
and he's not running on that now and
Trump is an evil madman who must be
removed Noam Chomsky has been very good
at distilling that every time he's asked
about this and he does it here in this
interview as well let's look at a sort
of condensed transcript and I actually
want to read through it because this
really matters Noam Chomsky said quote
this sounds strong but it's true
Trump is the worst criminal in history
undeniably there has never been a figure
in political history who was so
passionately dedicated to destroying the
projects for organized human life on
earth in the near future this is not an
exaggeration people are focused now on
the protests the pandemic is serious
enough that we will emerge from it at a
terrible cost the cost is greatly
amplified by the gangster in the White
House who has killed tens of thousands
of Americans making this the worst place
in the world for the coronavirus we will
emerge from the pandemic but we're not
going to emerge from another crime that
Trump has committed the heating of the
globe
the worst of it is coming we're not
going to emerge from that the ice sheets
are melting they're not going to recover
that leads to exponential increase in
global warming Arctic glaciers for
example could flood the world recent
studies indicate that on the present
course in about 50 years much of the
habitable part of the world will be
unlivable
you won't be able to live in parts of
South Asia parts of the Middle East
parts of the United States we're
approaching the point of a hundred and
twenty-five thousand years ago when sea
levels were about 25 feet higher than
they are now and it's worse than that
the scripps oceanographic institute just
came out with a study that estimated
that we are coming ominously close to a
point similar to three million years ago
when sea levels were 50 to 80 feet
higher than they are today
Noam Chomsky goes on to say quote all
around the world countries are trying to
do something about it but there is one
country which is led by a president who
wants to escalate the crisis to raced
toward the abyss to maximize the use of
fossil fuels including the most
dangerous of them and to dismantle the
regulatory apparatus that limits their
impact there is no crime like this in
human history nothing this is a unique
individual and it's not as if he doesn't
know what he's doing
of course he does it's as if he doesn't
care if he can pour more profits into
his pockets and the pockets of his rich
constituency tomorrow who cares if the
world disappears in a couple
of generations as far as the government
is concerned we're seeing something
pretty interesting parliamentary
democracy has been around for 350 years
starting in England in 1689 with the
so-called Glorious Revolution when
sovereignty was transferred from the
royalty to the Parliament the beginnings
of parliamentary democracy in the u.s.
came about a century later parliamentary
democracy is not just based on laws and
constitutions in fact the British
constitution is maybe a dozen words it's
based on trust and good faith the
assumption that people will act like
human beings and then after Chomsky
talks a little bit about Richard Nixon
and George W Bush Chomsky goes back to
quote it goes deep into issues well
before Trump but he is a unique
phenomenon again the worst criminal in
human history
so his minor crimes are to destroy
American democracy and to amplify a
pandemic killing over a hundred thousand
people but those are minor crimes by his
standards what's so important about this
is that Chomsky distills the importance
of not messing around with these sidebar
arguments what we're seeing is as bad as
I and others have been saying much of it
the incompetence the authoritarian
tendencies the ruined global alliances
the worsening crisis crisis of climate
change while Trump doesn't care they
were all completely predictable from day
one and I was not unique in predicting
it I'm not taking any unique credit for
predicting it this is not a time for
maybe I'll stay home or maybe I don't
care or I don't really like Biden or
whatever you contribute to the worsening
of the problem if you do that that's how
critical this is and I'm so glad that we
are hearing it from Noam Chomsky we'll
have some of these Chomsky quotes on the
show's Instagram page at David Pakman
show make sure you're following us there
also make sure you're following me on
Instagram at David Pakman I posted a
video of how I now drink water might be
interesting to some of you
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blink its
blink Isleta consumed an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video